COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
we help some DNA technicians
improve their upload speeds.
Will they get the folds
out of their genome
before their big meeting?
Stay tuned to find out.
DNA SOAP is a biotech
company whose main product
is a software that does protein
folding across distributed
machines.
Sadly, though, any time they
would provide a new data set
to be worked on, there
was a significant delay
before any clients would
start doing computation.
Their architecture was
pretty straightforward.
Once a new genome
data set came in,
it would get chopped up and
uploaded to Google Cloud
Storage, where clients, who were
listening for pub/sub updates,
would grab the work blocks
and start computing.
Now, here's the
interesting part.
The size of the
work blocks changed,
depending on how many
connected clients there
were to do the work.
So more workers resulted
in smaller work blocks
to balance out properly.
The problem at hand was
that the DNA SOAP software
was taking a really long time
to upload all the files to GCS
in regions with a really high
number of available workers.
To try and replicate this, I
created a small Python script,
which generated files
of various sizes,
and then uploaded each file
to a GCS regional bucket
about 100 times or so.
Turns out, the smaller
the files in your set,
the slower your upload speed.
The reason for this
is that there's
a certain amount of
transactional overhead
for uploading files.
So the smaller they are, the
more this overhead adds up.
The solution?
Parallel uploads.
gsutil provides the -m option,
which performs parallel
copy which can
significantly increase
the performance of an upload.
Now, when we chart the
performance against our base
state, we can see that the
parallel version provides
significantly higher
throughput since
the transactional overhead is
mitigated across many threats.
For DNA SOAP, this
small command line flag
resulted in a 2x improvement in
upload speed for their files,
not bad for a bunch
of scientists.
If you want to know more
about parallel uploads,
check out the associated article
listed in the description
below.
And don't forget to check
out the rest of our Cloud
Performance Atlas content.
When it comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]